merci Françoise Gatel de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes sénatrice centriste
Ille-et-Vilaine et vous présidez la
délégation sénatoriale au collectivité
territoriales et à la décentralisation
va bien sûr revenir dans quelques
instants sur les violences dont sont
victimes les élus mais d'abord vous avez
additionné Gérald Darmanin on l'a vu sur
les émeutes de ces derniers jours est-ce
que selon vous l'exécutif a bien géré la
situation
je dis je dis oui parce que j'ai trouvé
Gérald Darmanin très transparent
et c'était d'ailleurs extrêmement
intéressant parce qu'on voit que la
situation est plus complexe qu'on
pourrait spontanément le penser
c'est-à-dire ce ne sont pas que des
émeutes de banlieue on a bien vu
qu'elles avaient touché des villes qui
en 2005 ne l'avait pas été petit ouais
et que tous les biens ont été attaqués
qu'il y ait aussi des scènes de pillage
je trouve qu'il a il a géré cette
éruption volgouvernement d'une manière
qui permet aujourd'hui de dire que en
tout cas c'est un peu apaisé mais je
pense que le feu continue à à couver et
que je pense qu'il faut partir il peut
repartir oui je pense parce que alors
certainement que le décès tragique de ce
jeune qui nous attriste tous a été
un motif mais pour moi ça n'est pas que
ça n'est pas que la cause et que
justement il y a des causes
multifactorielles ou en tout cas des
facteurs extrêmement différents il y a
peut-être des choses à faire en matière
législatives réglementaire mais je pense
surtout qu'il y a à redéfinir un projet
de société partagé lesquels sur les
choses législatives il y a notamment la
question qui se pose sur est-ce qu'il
faut revoir la loi de 2017 qui régit
l'utilisation d'armes à feu par les
forces de l'ordre notamment en cas de
refus de obtempérer il faut la revoir
cette loi je pense que on est toujours
sur des réactions d'émotion donc il y a
un événement on fait une loi et
rappelez-vous que cette loi elle a quand
même été faite parce qu'on était à
l'époque d'attentat de terroriste et que
à cette époque la l'opinion et les
parlementaires estimaient que les
policiers devaient être en capacité de
réagir dans des conditions bien claires
et déterminées et cette disposition n'a
pas vraiment posé de problème à l'époque
aujourd'hui c'est un autre type de
situation qui se présentent à nous moi
je pense qu'il faut pas légiférer la 24
heures après un événement parce que
l'émotion qui guide l'action
bon voilà je pense que ça donne
satisfaction ce qui grandissent des
mesures miracus mais ça marche pas mais
c'est aussi ce qu'a dit Gérald
darmaninière il dit c'est pas parce que
un policier n'a pas respecté la loi
qu'il faut changer la loi c'est
exactement ça alors j'ai dit d'une
manière différente sans doute moins
clair c'est pas parce qu'il y a un
événement qui suicide de l'émotion que
l'on va modifier la loi et que là je
pense que cette loi elle avait sa
pertinence il y a un policier qui agit
d'une manière qui semble-t-il ne
respecte pas la déontologie la justice a
été saisie enfin le travail a été fait
et je pense qu'il faut cesser
d'instrumentaliser et l'événement
tragique du décès de ce jeune homme et
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui j'en ai
bien il y a trop d'instrumentalisations
pour servir d'autres causes qui ne sont
pas toutes nobles Gérald Darmanin l'a
également rappelé hier moyen d'acheter
en tout cas des interpeller 17-18 ans
ils sont très jeunes ils sont mineurs
est-ce qu'il faut sanctionner les
parents de ses émeutiers ont suspendant
voir en supprimant les allocations
familiales là encore moi je pense que on
peut pas répondre oui ou non mais il
faut s'interroger c'est à dire je pense
qu'il y a un vrai sujet de
responsabilité des parents le premier
lieu d'éducation de socialisation c'est
la famille il y a des familles pour qui
c'est extrêmement difficile quand vous
êtes une femme toute seule que vous
élevez vos enfants que vous avez un
travail en en décalé c'est compliqué
donc il faut que notre société est
s'organise pour accompagner les familles
mais qu'à un moment moi je pense que
vous ne pouvez pas avoir que des droits
à un moment ce type d'allocation
a été créé pour accompagner des si à un
moment on voit qu'il y a pas de la
difficulté à faire parce que les gens
sont dans la détresse et là il faut les
aider mais que si on voit qu'il y a des
gens qui n'en ont rien à faire de de de
leur enfant moi je pense que la société
elle se doit de régir et que parfois il
faut mettre les enfants à l'abri
soit on va dire de de parents qui pour
des raisons diverses ou variées pense
qu'il y a d'autres sujets de
préoccupations il faut protéger les
enfants et permettre que on intègre les
enfants dans la société ce qui permettra
peut-être d'éviter
des emballements et des embrassements
comme on connaît et on l'a vu c'est un
jour une fois de plus les mers en
première ligne face à ses émeutières
vous avez fait une autre audition c'est
celle de la ministre des collectivités
territoriales Dominique Faure auditionné
par les sénateurs sur les réponses à
apporter face aux violences on va
regarder les temps forts de cette
audition avec Mathias Arès
[Musique]
en fait on entend quand même beaucoup de
mer hier dire que ça aurait été bien
pire des actions positives il y en a eu
il faut réinterroger encore une fois une
partie des actions il faut compléter le
dispositif il faut pas accuser le
gouvernement de pas avoir mis les moyens
la critique est facile l'art est
difficile ce pacte comprend trois
principaux axes la plateforme Pharos
pour signaler tous types de
cyber-harcèlement à l'encontre des mers
un effectif de 3400 gendarmes qui
accompagnent la protection des élus
passant de référents élus à référent
violence envers les élus et puis enfin
la possibilité pour les maires de
s'enregistrer sur le 17 la ministre a
annoncé que 1800 élus était déjà
inscrits sur ce registre et revoir la
sécurité des élus c'est une question qui
fait consensus chez les Sénateurs oui
tous dans l'assemblée était d'accord
pour dire que la situation est très
grave et qu'il faut agir mais pour
certains comme Patrick kaner cela ne va
pas assez vite et le président du groupe
socialiste dénonce l'inaction d'un
gouvernement qui a toujours un temps de
retard
vous pouvez pas excusez-moi balader la
représentation nationale de petits
textes en petit texte surtout en ayant
coupé la branche de l'autonomie globale
politique des des maires dans dans ce
pays vous allez me dire je ne suis pas
responsable nous sommes tous
responsables mais vous êtes aux
responsabilités centrale il faut que
vous entendiez cette colère profonde les
mers ne peuvent pas être les variables
d'ajustement de l'incurie politique de
ce gouvernement madame Gatel vous
partagez le constat du président Kanner
le gouvernement se défaussent un petit
peu alors oui non je suis dire Patrick
Kanner c'est quelqu'un de très bien mais
là franchement c'est pas le niveau quoi
quand il dit que les mères peuvent pas
être les variables d'ajustement
excusez-moi mais sauf être frappé
d'amnésie moi je me rappelle d'un
quinquennat qui était celui de Monsieur
Hollande ou les mains et les
collectivités étaient bien les variables
d'ajustement budgétaires donc mon père
de fonctionnement exactement bon
maintenant il s'agit pas de dire c'est
un fauteuil du ou la faute durant moi je
pense qu'il y a déjà dans la loi des
choses enfin on s'est battu au Sénat
dans 3ds et dans engagement et proximité
qui remontent au décès du maire de signe
enfin 2019 il y a des choses dans la loi
la protection fonctionnelle des élus une
obligation pour les magistrats pour la
justice pour les procureurs
d'organiser un lien précis avec les
maires il y a des départements aussi
fait d'une manière remarquable et
magistrale voilà donc les mains ils ont
ce que j'appelle un filet de sécurité
autour d'eux il faut bien dire à nos
concitoyens qu'il ne s'agit pas de
permettre à des mères dans frein de la
loi mais pendant des années on a fait du
bashing d'élus voilà donc aujourd'hui
l'élu voilà c'est quelqu'un qui se donne
une autorité que d'autres contestent
alors qu'il faut vraiment le sécuriser
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions c'est
que ça donc mettons en place
ce qui existe permettons ce que ce que
nous avons voté au Sénat c'est à dire le
niveau de peine pour des agressions vers
les élus que nous avons demandé
équivalent potentiellement
on va on va revenir sur ces questions de
protection mais juste sur les maires qui
ont dû faire face à des émeutes il y a
notamment des conséquences dans les
communes Emmanuel Macron lorsqu'il a
reçu les maires il a promis une loi
d'urgence qui devrait être examinée
avant l'été donc d'ici 8 jours vous la
voterez cette loi alors il faut d'abord
que je sache qu'il y a dedans mais ce
que j'ai la bonne réponse ou pas mais ce
que j'ai compris c'est que il y a
effectivement de l'urgence donc moi j'ai
trouvé positif que le Président de la
République il entend de les maires et
que les mers se sentent écoutés enfin
qui puissent avoir ce temps de parler
mais ça suffit pas effectivement s'il y
a des dispositions d'urgence sans doute
qu'elles vont ressembler à la
proposition loi qui a été déposée au
Sénat par Sophie prima que j'ai consigné
qui consiste à dire qu'il y a urgence
comparer une école à réparer une mairie
enfin on peut pas attendre des
collectivités voilà et que donc ce que
j'ai compris c'est dans l'esprit de ce
que Sophie prima propose et que j'ai
donc consigné qui est vraiment une aide
exceptionnelle pour aider les mères à
aller très vite essayer de dépasser les
règles des marchés publics et que l'État
ou la nation la République Vienne en
solidarité avec les mères donc si ça
c'est très bien ça il faut il faut
absolument qu'on qu'on le fasse et vous
parliez de la protection des élus madame
Gatel et Mathias a des propositions qui
émanent du Sénat pour accélérer les
choses justement il y a une proposition
de loi qui a été déposée par le
président de la commission des lois
François Noel buffet il y a pratiquement
un mois et qui vise à renforcer la
sécurité des élus en augmentant
significativement les sanctions pénales
pour des faits de violence contre les
élus une autre proposition de loi qui
émane cette fois du groupe socialiste
envisage de créer un statut d'élus
meilleure reconnaissance une meilleure
rémunération un accès peut-être plus
ouvert à des profils pourraient se
sentir éloigné de l'engagement citoyen
ça vous parle ça madame la sénatrice oh
ça fait plus que me parler parce que on
l'a déjà encore une fois on a initié des
choses
par deux fois dans de textes de loi et
que vous savez aujourd'hui le président
du Sénat présentera des propositions
issues d'un groupe de travail très
écuminique transpartisan qui travaille
depuis le mois d'octobre et vous verrez
que dans ces propositions mais je vais
rien dévoiler on est grande ligne
c'est-à-dire non non je ne dirais rien
vous vous ne me ferez pas parler même
sous la menace mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que on a deux sujets c'est
permettre au maire de pouvoir agir voilà
et en même temps donner envie de servir
et de s'engager et que longue il faut
sécuriser les mers les protéger et il
faut aussi avoir ce statut de l'élu qui
fait que quand vous vous engagez pour
servir la population vous perdez pas des
points de retraite vous soyez pas en
difficulté le jour où votre mandat c'est
ce que vous soyez une protection comment
on fait n'importe quel salarié partout
parce que vous voyez bien pardon que en
2020 il y a 106 communes où il y a pas
eu de candidats et que je voudrais pas
enfin si je vais le faire rappeler ce
phénomène de découragement et des
engagements
renforcés par la peur des familles de
voir un de leurs proches bousculés
physiquement ou moralement juste parce
qu'il est main et qui s'engageait pour
servir sur la sécurité il y a eu le
maire de Saint-Brévin maintenant celui
de L'Haÿ-les-Roses la proposition de loi
de François Noel buffet ne devrait
arriver à l'agenda que début octobre
est-ce qu'il ne faut pas accélérer une
fois pour toutes sur ces dossiers quand
même alors moi je pense que octobre ça
va quand même mine de rien ça va j'ose
pas dire que ça va c'est je vous
rappelle qu'il y a des élections et que
je pense que aujourd'hui cette loi il y
a deux choses on fait une loi faut
qu'elle soit appliquée donc ça veut dire
aussi et je le dis voilà en respectant
l'indépendance de la justice mais la
justice est en duo au nom du peuple
français et je pense que la justice doit
aussi se saisir de dispositifs de
sanctions qui existent et que je trouve
que
il n'y a pas toujours matière est
extrêmement satisfait de la justice doit
être plus rapide et on lui a donné des
moyens et elle doit vraiment sanctionner
d'une manière quand je dis juge je veux
dire pertinente et je pense qu'on a
aussi des progrès à faire donc elle est
plus rapide et plus sévère
elle doit appliquer enfin je veux dire
excuse-moi mais on en a un petit peu
parlé au Sénat vous avez vu je pense que
quand il y a des circulaires qui sont
des anti circulaires à celle du garde
des sceaux qui font que parfois on peut
avoir un regard un peu indulgent sur des
gens qui commet des actes délictuels
soit de vandalisme soit de l'agression
bon je pense que là faut que chacun se
ressaisisse mais du coup est-ce qu'il
faut renforcer encore les sanctions ou
est-ce qu'il faut déjà commencer par
appliquer réellement les sanctions qui
existent déjà
je pense que il faut déjà appliquer ce
qui existe il faut être rapide vous
voyez on a une collègue sénatrice qui
porte plainte parce que à un moment
quelqu'un a tenu un propos à son égard
qui est on lui dit qu'il y aura une
audience au mois de septembre la chose
est arrivée il y a très peu de temps
l'audience est reportée en 2024 un an et
demi après et c'est pas dossier qui
nécessite des gens et des jours de
l'instruction alors la justice elle est
sans doute engourdi parce que elle est
débordée mais je pense que la sanction
elle doit être exemplaire pour être
éducatif et que ça veut dire qu'elle est
proportionnée mais qu'elle doit être
rapide parce que si vous décalez le
jugement par rapport à l'événement tout
ça c'est parti dans les oublis ainsi que
nous nous proposons encore une fois
d'élever les sanctions possibles à
l'échelle au niveau de celle qui peuvent
être utilisés ou prononcer quand un
policier ou un gendarme et ceci
uniquement dans l'exercice du
manademaire c'est pas de l'impunité hier
lors de l'audition de Dominique fort
vous avez parlé du fait de travailler
sur la formation des magistrats des
policiers et des gendarmes que faut-il
faire moi je pense sincèrement pour
avoir été maire longtemps et présidente
de l'association permet de mon
département moi j'ai vu à un moment une
commande une méconnaissance totale de
ces deux univers et que vous aviez
rappelez-vous une défiance a priori à
l'enconque des élus c'est à dire élus
c'était celui qui avait sûrement fait
des trucs un peu bizarres il aurait
entre guillemets profitez d'eux vous
voyez alors il y a eu des cas moi je
n'ai pas mais aujourd'hui pour avoir un
cas d'élus un peu borderline vous avez
une grande majorité enfin vous avez des
centaines de milles qui sont pas mal bon
et donc la justice avait ce regard de
défiance ou de méfiance et elle va
regarder un peu achat donc il y a une
méconnaissance et que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui dans la formation des
magistrats il faut qu'ils découverte de
ce qu'est cet univers des élus ce qu'est
l'exercice de leur fonction et encore
une fois c'est pas pour que les mains
soient à côté de la loi pas du tout mais
qu'il puisse exercer la fonction qui est
la leur pour laquelle ils ont été élus
à tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure on
parlera de Tour de France et
d'engagement financier des collectivités
territoriales sur cette question là
exactement ce sera à suivre dans le club
on va continuer à parler des mères on va
aller chez vous en Ille-et-Vilaine on
retrouve Stéphane bonjour Stéphane merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
directeur de l'information de TV Rennes
et aujourd'hui s'ouvre à Rennes le salon
terre et mer le rassemblement des mers
d'Ille-et-Vilaine l'occasion pour les
élus de partager leur préoccupations il
y a bien sûr Stéphane on en a parlé avec
Françoise Gatel les questions de
sécurité et d'agression des lunes mais
il y a bien d'autres sujets d'inquiétude
oui il y a bien d'autres sujets
d'inquiétude il y aura d'ailleurs la
présence du ministre Christophe bichu
aujourd'hui ce salon va rassembler 333
communes on va parler énormément de
sujets d'inquiétude vous l'avez dit la
commande publique les transitions
énergétiques la rénovation des bâtiments
le statut de l'élu Françoise Gatel en a
parlé mais le terme central c'est le
pouvoir d'agir Françoise Gatel eu une
question les maires parlent beaucoup
aujourd'hui du fameux âne cette vraiment
engagement zéro artificialisation nette
on fait comment lorsque l'on est à la
tête d'une commune aujourd'hui
principalement dans un département comme
Ille-et-Vilaine qui est un département
rural c'est une vraie question de
parlementaire c'est-à-dire
nous nous disons que l'économie du
foncier c'est à dire arrêtez de s'étaler
dans la campagne nécessaire et c'est
très important on est d'accord sur
l'objectif de transition écologique
maintenant c'est comment on atteint
l'objectif en sachant qu'il faut
réindustrialiser la France pour être
dans une économie de souveraineté et
comment on loge des gens vous l'avez dit
Stéphane en Bretagne on est une région
très attractive et on s'en réjouit mais
comment on accueille des gens comment on
peut les loger si le foncier est rare et
donc cher en france vous allez avoir
plus de 4 millions et demi de logements
qui ne seront plus disponibles à la
location parce que ce sont des patients
thermiques comment on fait si on a plus
ces logements que on ne peut plus
construire d'une manière mesurer modérée
et je veux dire dans le pays de Rennes
on l'a déjà fait depuis 2003 on consomme
deux fois moins
d'hectares donc moi je vous avoue que je
suis perplexe et que
l'écologie la transition elle doit être
heureuse et positive c'est-à-dire on ne
va pas entasser les gens dans des tours
de 25 étages mettre les usines à la
campagne et avoir des déserts ça n'est
pas possible ce qu'on ne va pas savoir
faire et qu'en plus c'est un modèle
social qui génère enfin je fais le lien
avec le sujet tout à l'heure si les gens
sont dans un contexte
d'habitat difficile un peu tendu ça
génère les les révoltes enfin en tout
cas les tensions qu'on connaît et donc
ça crée de la dissension sociale le
Lausanne juste pour qu'on prenne bien
c'est que un élu ne pourra plus bétonner
et construire son compenser par une
surface équivalente en espace vert il
est sénateurs ont commencé par voter ce
texte avec notamment ce qu'on appelle
une garantie rurale avec des protections
du coup pour les élus le texte est
arrivé à l'Assemblée nationale et
aujourd'hui député sénateurs doivent
d'accord est-ce que vous êtes optimiste
sur un accord oui comme si moi je suis
un peu comme saint Thomas sur ce sujet
là c'est à dire que je crois qu'on a
bien expliqué l'enjeu les élus sont
vertus
bon maintenant il faut qu'on avance il
faut qu'on change de modèle on est ok
mais en même temps encore une fois
comment on va conjuguer tout ce qu'on a
fait si c'est pour dire aujourd'hui on
est plus que vertu on est carrément des
assets parce que on ne mangera plus un
sol hectare dans notre pays en 2050 mais
si on n'a pas réussi à construire des
usines si on n'a pas construit on n'a
pas réussi
de la capacité de la majorité
présidentielle et d'exécutif à écouter
les élus locaux ce texte ah bah moi je
suis allée lundi département où
récemment je suis pas arrivé depuis 10
minutes on dit bonjour les ah au fait tu
ferais qu'on parle du jean parce que à
la ville comme à la campagne à la mer
comme à la montagne les élus comment on
fait donc il faut qu'on change il y a
pas de sujet mais en même temps vous ne
pouvez pas éteindre la lumière dans la
campagne et vous ne pouvez pas expliquer
un maire qui a besoin d'accueillir des
gens pour garder son école que ça ne va
peut-être pas être possible et que je
pense que Christophe béchure il a
entendu maintenant l'heure de vérité
c'est ce matin est-ce que on va
comprendre au moment où on nous dit que
les mains sont vraiment des gens
formidables extraordinaires qu'ils ont
tout compris qui vont sauver la France
est-ce que c'est vrai je pense est-ce
que là on comprend ce qu'on dit Stéphane
vous avez d'autres questions
oui une autre question c'est la triste
Gatel au printemps ce sont déroulés les
états généraux de la simplification je
vais vous citer vous aviez dit à cette
occasion je vous cite que la boulimie
normative bloque parfois les élus dans
leurs actions alors il y a un sondage
qui montre que 75 % des maires se
trouvent un peu isolé dans leurs actions
par rapport à l'état la grande question
qui saura aussi en filigrane de ces deux
journées à l'occasion de se congrès des
mères d'Ille-et-Vilaine que vous avez
présidé est-ce que vraiment il est grand
temps Françoise Gatel de changer les
choses mais si on croit qu'il n'est
jamais trop tard effectivement c'est
c'est maintenant et tout le temps parce
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement le premier
motif d'insatisfaction des mers ce sont
ces normes qui empêchent et je vous
citerai juste une anecdote qui vous
permettez je connais une petite commune
d'Ille-et-Vilaine ou le maire a voulu
mettre en accessibilité handicapé des
bâtiments publics sur une toute petite
place autour peut-être de splato vous
avez une église une mairie une salle des
fêtes et il a fallu pour chacun de ces
bâtiments avoir deux places de
stationnement handicapés sur ce parking
il y avait 12 ou 15 places ça veut dire
que vous avez six places qui sont
réservés aux personnes en accessibilité
c'est très bien moi je ne dis pas qu'il
faut pas le faire mais quand vous
réfléchissez vous voyez que quand
l'église est ouverte pour la messe c'est
le dimanche la mairie est fermée et
quand la mairie est ouverte l'église est
fermée la salle des fêtes et que donc on
aurait eu trois places au lieu de 6
c'était suffisant parce que ensuite le
maire n'a cessé de se faire engueuler
parce qu'il y avait sur le parking 5
places qui étaient vides que les gens ne
pouvaient pas utiliser les valides parce
qu'ils ont une infraction il sait pas où
se garer vous voyez c'est de dire non
mais est-ce qu'on peut faire les choses
bien respecter l'accessibilité pourtant
mais en même temps être juste dans la
proportion quoi faut qu'on les mains ils
sont aujourd'hui mais vraiment empêcher
d'agir et on a une constitution et qu'un
principe de précaution donc
l'administration elle fait tout pour que
rien n'arrive et que non seulement à
rien n'arrive d'ennuyeux mais l'action
que vous devez faire vous n'arrivez même
pas à la produire et donc nous on
demande à ce que le préfet il soit
l'arbitre de tous les services de l'État
et qu'à un moment ils permettent aux
mains de faire le travail qu'il a à
faire c'est de rendre service aux gens
merci Stéphane Besnier merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous évidemment vous
retrouve très vite et merci Françoise
Gatel d'avoir été notre invité pendant
cette première demi-heure on vous
retrouve à la rentrée avec plaisir merci
Françoise Gatel d'avoir été avec nous
dans cinq minutes dans le club des
territoires on parlera du Tour de France
on sait que la Bretagne adore le Tour de
France j'adore et là il est dans les
Pyrénées